Hmm.
Ooh.
Oh.
How does one define simplicity?
Very good question.
Uh,
to me it is just,
uh,
a distilled thought,
something that registers quickly.
Um,
it doesn't require a lot of
explanations,
seems intuitively obvious,
that kind of a thing.
And I think,
uh,
a lot of businesses out there tend to
put things in terms,
uh,
that require more,
more fought study or whatever.
And I think what made steve jobs is such
a genius was that he had this belief in
the power of simplicity and he wanted to
ensure that his products embodied that
and the way the company communicated
with people embodied that.
So I think simplicity is this thing.
It's a concept really that gets applied
to so many different things.
It's not just,
Oh,
look at the simple product.
It's,
it's the whole structure of the
organization as the belief system.
All that stuff is based on this idea
that,
that human beings have,
uh,
a built in desire for simpler things.
We just don't like to Labor over complex
issues.
And when someone has something to,
to share with us,
whether it's a product or service or
whatever,
that the people who,
who really understand that simplicity is
a very powerful thing.
Those are the people who,
who establish an emotional connection
with their customers,
which is something that apple was very,
very good at doing.
I do think that simplicity is one of the
hardest things you can do.
And it is deceptive in that way because
it looks simple.
Um,
the way I like to put it is that there
is no such thing as simplicity.
There is only the perception of
simplicity that every simple thing we
see in this world,
whether it's an iphone,
obviously years worth of research goes
into making the little things that make
an iphone.
But you could look at a simple website
and,
uh,
we all know we who create such things
know that this beautifully simple site
that you've,
you've built could have been the result
of,
of weeks or months of,
of anguish,
debate and differences of opinion and
arguments and whatever.
And you end up with something that's
simple.
So what's really important is the
perception of simplicity.
Uh,
did have,
if someone walks away from the
experience and that it was simple,
that's,
you know,
mission accomplished.
But I think getting there is really,
really hard.
It requires all that commitment and uh,
energy.
It,
it,
it doesn't come easily.
I guess that's the point.
But when you do get there,
it becomes very,
very worth it.
In fact,
there's a great steve jobs quote,
it's always about Steve Jobs,
isn't it,
where he said that,
um,
it takes a lot of hard work to make
something simple,
but it's worth it in the end because
once you get there,
you can move mountains.
And I think those are great words to
live by.
But he understood that that was the,
the,
the challenge for apple was to take
really cool products and really cool
capabilities and put them in a,
in a form that people could so easily
relate to and,
and take advantage of without thick
manuals and that kind of a thing.
So that's the real work is,
is making great things simple.
The big question is how do you do it?
Where does simplicity come from?
And that's a question I hear all the
time.
And um,
you know,
I have some humble suggestions on that
topic.
Um,
I think because simple is such a simple
thing,
it comes along with some simple advice
and I think that one of the most
important things you can do is simply
step back and look at your,
what you're doing through the eyes of
the customer.
I believe that that was Steve Jobs,
amazing strength that he looked at this
experience that apple was creating and
he looked at it with a super critical
eye.
What would he think as a customer?
I think that a lot of,
uh,
company leaders don't do that as well as
Steve.
And I think you can criticize your own
products and services and your website
and all that stuff.
Um,
you can excuse your own lapses by
saying,
yeah,
well we did the best we could because we
had these certain issues and that's how
we dealt with it.
But that's the difference between,
you know,
a regular person in a steve jobs,
kind of a person.
Steve was just,
I'm sorry,
no compromises allowed.
And if you suggest to me that we're
going to compromise,
you know,
your future here is probably not very
good.
He believed that the user experience
with all important.
So I always tell people,
you know,
the best place to start for me is to
just be the customer and look at every
part of the customer experience from the
very first ad they might see to the
website,
to what the retail experiences like,
you know,
how hard it is to order when you get the
product,
what does it feel like to open it up and
start experiencing it.
And the then of course,
the design of the product,
the interface,
uh,
when you need help,
what's,
you know,
how easy is it to get support the whole
bit.
So you create this experience that is
simple for people and you know,
fails to,
um,
to confuse them in a very,
very good way.
So,
you know,
you look at all the choices some people
provide to their customers.
Uh,
you know,
with all the best intentions,
you might go to a website and there are
20 different products to choose from.
Whereas a company that really believes
in simplicity might say here are three
and we've thought it all out of there,
three kinds of people here.
There's,
you know,
the small,
medium and large or whatever it is.
Um,
that make it easy for you to make a
decision rather than,
than,
you know,
force you to think too hard and then
wonder after you made the purchase
whether you might've made a big mistake
and that kind of a thing.
So I think apple again has been very
good at,
at doing that kind of a thing.
So it's customers go away feeling pretty
confident that they got the right thing
and they enjoy the experience.
But all along the way,
all these decisions that must be made,
uh,
need to be looked at with that kind of
brutal bit of,
you know,
self analysis that is the experience so
good that you would actually tell your
friends about it and say,
you got to look at this thing with me.
I,
I love this thing and you're going to
like it to,
or is it just kind of like,
okay,
and you know,
I'd buy it.
And then,
you know,
I'm not sure if I'd tell anyone about
it,
but that's,
you know,
it,
it worked for me,
that kind of a thing.
And I think in the world of Steve Jobs,
it was always about making the
experience like amazingly good.
And,
and too many people are willing to
compromise that away.
Simplicity requires that kind of,
that,
that brutal assessment of what is
really,
really good versus what's good enough
and what's good enough isn't good
enough.
It's gotta be really,
really good.
Okay.
So you're mister simplicity.
What about your personal life?
As simple as that?
And the answer is not at all really.
And I'm working on it,
but I think simplicity is something that
works in business and it should work and
your personal life as well.
Um,
and it's,
it's a gratifying way to live and work.
I think there's something very
satisfying about having this kind of
space in your life and the order and the
lack of clutter and the,
and the firm direction.
But you know,
life is complicated and that's,
and it's because life is complicated.
That's simplicity stands out.
So we got to take the good with the bad.
You know,
we live in this complicated world,
but that actually gives us an
opportunity to be more noticed by being
simple.
So whether it's business or personal,
uh,
simplest,
he has that kind of power.
Ooh.